so hi everyone welcome to this session
my name is tessar garciaa and I would
like all of you to learn more in this
tutorial about open data open data
quality and how to use some python tools
like great expectation s be to make the
most out of the data quality of this
data set for the last uh years I've been
working really hard on open data and how
to make the most of the data that is
available for everyone to use
and sometimes there are like nasty
problems with data quality in the data
sets so I like to just go ahead and
share this tutorial session so all of
you can learn how to use these tools to
assess the quality of the on on open
data data set and then uh find out if
you can improve certain aspects uh of
the data set to make it more useful or
to fix some problems that prevent you
from doing some data analysis task or
just to research about open data
expenditures or whatever is your topic
of choice there are so many things that
are going
on um in open data so there is at least
10 to 10,000 data set that might be
useful to whatever you are trying to
lean towards so I see there are some
people coming to this talk and really
happy to welcome you all and now we're
going to start this this tutorial
session where like I say it's going to
be quite handson before I start with the
technical aspect of the
presentation this is kind of the agenda
for today we are going to be talking
about open data and open data Quality
Concepts for the first 10 to 15 minutes
so you can learn more about what do we
mean when we talk about data quality
that maybe it's a bit abstract content
then we'll spend most of the session on
validation of single data sets how can
we just take a data set from an open
data source and then just transform it
into something that is better than the
one you got from the Internet or for
whatever portal you call it then we will
spend the around 20 minutes doing the
preparing longitudinal data how do we
get this year over-ear data set so we
have the same data and the same format
for all the years in both and then we
will just keep the last 10 minutes for
the Q&A so you have any question just
feel free to drop them in the platform
and the host and the co-host will help
me just putting them on screen and
getting them solved as soon as possible
so what tools are we going to use today
we are going to use GRE expectations we
are going to use pandas and sweet bits I
assume most of you attending Pata Global
conference are
very familiar with pandas but maybe you
are not so familiar with the other tool
presented so by at the end of the
session I expect you to be able just to
use these tools on your day-to-day task
to improve the data quality and to do
the exploratory data analysis
task so before we move further um I
would suggest you if you want to to go
along with the session and want to try
things on your own this there is this
repo I'm going just to copy and paste
the whole uh URL in the chat so if you
just want to uh
there are kind of two options either you
are going
to run it on your local PC that I for me
that's the best way to to run it like
just clone the rapo and create
everything on your local PC and then
everything works the data is already
included here on the on the repo and you
don't have to download anything extra
but other than that you can also try to
run it in in collab and and these are
kind of the steps you need to open cab.
research. google.com the file menu just
go and open notebook this is in Spanish
so if you are following other languages
it's open notebook and then you will
have the
GitHub well it's this is kind of the
issue with the collab time that if you
don't write for a while maybe it will
time out and then you will need to
reload it but if you click here on the
sing data sets and this is a Jupiter
notebook and you will be able just to to
run the whole experiment and there is a
sell just for collab users because like
I said whenever you are opening the data
set you need to install your
requirements and you need to install
kind of every everything and also you
need to download manually the data set
we're going to use if you are running
this locally you will have no issues
just going there and running the the the
Jupiter network from the start to the
end
so what are we going to do today is kind
of explore open data and figure out what
is the quality and how to make it world
for you so one little I I I wrote a note
so I didn't forgot about it so great
expectation is not officially supported
on Windows but it works I mean
everything you will be seeing today is
running on Windows and the thing about
Windows support is mostly related to the
problem of being able
to pop up new windows from the browser
and this is something that is is not
really consistent on windows so this is
the reason that one of the reasons that
h r expectation is not officially
supported on windows so your Mill is by
depending on the on the source so
Alexandra has just shared an the link to
the repo it's going to be pinned on the
chat window so if we you want to go
along with the coding session it's going
to be really really nice just follow the
instruction just follow the r me and you
can do this will I go on with the next
steps so let's do a brief introduction
about G data quality because usually
when we talk about data quality there
are so many perspective everyone has a
their own vision of what is the quality
their own ideas and I like to introduce
the basics so all of us have this kind
of common knowledge this common
vocabulary that will help us like do it
better so in a summary what this talk is
about is like okay we all of us know
pandas all know how to do some data
cleaning but well there are some
standards there are some manners there
are some establish ways to measure data
quality so there are some International
standards like ISO
25,000 12 that deal just with data
quality so even though we are going to
see pandas we are going to try to to
frame how pandas work inside this kind
of Standards base so we are not
Reinventing the wheel we are
just pushing forward and standardized
quality for all our data sets the more
people just sh kind of this knowledge
and the same framework the easier is
going to be to move forward
so whenever we approach a new file uh as
python users usually we load pandas and
we start firing like okay let's figure
out if there are duplicates let's figure
out if there are um n let's figure out
if any column is kind of empty let's
just set the correct data type because
maybe you are just maybe you're just
typing and there oh this was imported as
an object I want this to be a data time
whatever there are a lot of functions
that can be used to do this data
cleaning but most of the times this is
not standardized most people do not have
like a clear set of steps just to move
forward it's more like okay I want to
try these two three four things and
whenever it looks okay we move forward
with the analysis and then later on we
find the problem that oh then we
discover another problem then we have to
go back fix it again go back so I'm just
trying to avoid this kind of one shot
where you go ahead and say okay I'm
going to fix everything manually I'm
trying to promote another approach that
is kind of more rigorous so if you want
to know more about these International
standards you can kind of read on these
ISO notes or in on the data management
association thebook and even there are
some new
standards in the in the laws in the
European Union for the artificial
intelligence law there ston if you are
Spanish speaker you this is you are very
fortunate because the national
standardization office has just
published these guides in English and by
the time we are having this presentation
these are available for free so if you
want to learn from the actual standards
they are available for you to to move
forward so what do we mean by data
quality so the data quality of a data
product might be understood as the
degree to which data satisfy the
requirement defined by the product owner
organization this looks very nice but
might not be really easy to to
comprehend so my S definition is to the
what is the exent to which the data
characteristics are fit for purpose and
you may say what do you mean by data
characteristics what what are the
characteristics so let's take a side
step and look at actual non data example
so if we were choosing a suit and we
were like trying to say oh this is the
optional suit for me is this really nice
we might just start creating a table or
drafting like okay there are some
features related to the special to to
how the the shoe is it's the material
aspects for example what is the size and
maybe this is the length the width maybe
there is also an angle so you if you
don't step like really flat you might
need some correction and then there are
the materials and you have to find out
what is the optional sue for me and of
course you will need a certain length a
certain width maybe a certain angle but
if
we take a step back from this optimal
Sue there is not such an optimal shoe
this optimal shoe for a particular
purpose so whenever we dealing with data
we also need to ask the very same
question what is the what are the needs
what what do I need data to be for me to
be able to do an analysis otherwise you
are all the time trying to find the
perfect data set that maybe doesn't
exist so it's it's very interesting to
ask yourself okay whenever I'm dealing
with this data
quality that has all these kind of
properties metrics characteristics what
is our purpose I am trying to do some
check and balances to my government I'm
trying to find out what are the spots
where most traffic accidents happen
maybe I'm a biker I want to find the
best routs in my city so this street
that have the less accident ratio
compared to other streets whatever
whenever I'm approaching a data set I
need to figure out what is the purpose
what do I want to analyze because
depending on what you're trying to do
maybe the data set is optimal for you or
maybe you need some extra
adjustments adjustments in what kind of
Dimensions you might be asking and one
wondering so when we are talking about
these characteristics they are like kind
of in the iso 22 this is the there are
kind of two
different um two different fields some
of the characteristics are inherent of
the data set so if you get the data set
everything you need to calculate
everything you need to figure out it's
in the data files themselves other than
that there other features that are
dependent on the system so for example
the availability how portable is it how
recoverable this might be more dependent
of who is serving the or the ways that
the the portal is serving you the files
and so whenever we're talking about data
sets we will be getting in at least in
our case we will be ler focus on
inherent data quality and data quality
is is composed of several
characteristics that are accuracy
completeness consistency credibility and
corness and for each of these there
are properties so for example let's say
I'm going to go with a date maybe one
date if if we are talking about accuracy
syntastic accuracy means does this date
conform to a standard is this in maybe
in Spanish um Regional settings or
Regional configuration or does it adhere
to us standards for dates whenever we're
talking about semantic we are talking
about does this thing look like a date
for example if I have a column of years
and inside the column of years there is
a month this is kind of a semantic
inacurate
um finding because I'm expecting to find
years and then I find something that is
absolutely different from years so for
each of these there are some metrics to
record and there are things that you can
calculate for example are all the
records in are all the values complete
everything that can be measured we need
to to keep this in our head because
whenever we're
measuring this will help us to Define
and find out if you are completely
measuring the quality if we are missing
some aspects so what is the process like
to Define data quality the process
basically goes to number one Define what
are do requisites what do I need and
this is kind of an example here we have
screen each user account in the bank
will have an Associated uh one or more
iban accounts so every single account
will have this and from this business
rule there are some data quality
requisites like iban but like I mean
every account will have an Ean that must
not be not n every Evan number has to be
well formatted so for Bank accounts this
might be like for example our
requirements whenever we're dealing with
this we just find the data requisite
then we find out the data quality
requisites and these two are different
the first thing it was the what is the
business asking for and the second one
is to what extent this requisite is
fulfilled maybe H all the Eva numbers
have to be well formatted but maybe at
least 95% this is something you have to
figure out and this will help you that
just to create your rules last but not
least what is open data all this time I
have been talking about open data so let
me do a brief
introduction according to the open data
handbook open data is data that can be
freely used reused and redistribute by
anyone subject only at most to the
requirement to attribute or S likee so
it's like creative commands for data
it's like data that you can get you can
kind of reuse for whatever mean you want
and the only thing you have to do is
attribute where is the data coming from
so for today we are going to be using
Toronto open data data sets so in the
last 10 years the growth of data sets
available at the open data portal is has
been kind
of you you will see here on the screen
for the 10 years ago there were like 100
1,000 data set we in the 7 2,000 data
set and in European Union there are more
than 1.5 million data sets that you can
get for free and you can use for all
your projects here all your project all
your business whatever you're not
limited in terms of what to do the main
problem is that on this first decade
quantity has Trum quality so most in in
several cases you go to the data set and
then you say oh this is not what I was
expecting and this is this is kind of a
problem but the main issue with quality
is that the data quality depends on
purpose so maybe the publisher said
every single date here we have on screen
has a proper date so it's perfect for me
if you are coming from a python point of
view you might be saying no every single
date is is different it's a different
format I need
to No it's it's not right the data
quality is super poor but it's kind of a
different way to you know to see the
same data and have different opin opions
and it's the product owner the one that
determines what are the rules so what we
will see today Great Expectations will
help us document and validate our
expectations about the
data okay in terms of data quality there
are some pioneers and this is the reason
I I I have like pushed forward to use
open data Toronto as our example and
they publish for every data set and data
quality score what is the data quality
score made of so it's made of usability
do the columns have um names that
resemble the
content metadata what what percentage of
the metadata is completed is it really
fresh the data has been published
recently the there are no n registry
registers in the data set everything
here in this formula can be calculated
and whenever we are going to get a data
quality score we need to find out what
our weights what are going to be the
different values we're getting into and
then calculating them H and the weights
are absolutely dependent on what is the
purpose so in this case for example
Toronto just run some sessions with
their users with the stakeholders and
said what do you care the most about in
our data and they created this formula
and then applied it to every single data
set in the portal so you might be
wondering okay but you talk about you
talk about pandas and why why why pandas
is not the solution well in my opinion
pandas is part of the solution but it's
not the whole picture there there are a
lot of steps before you go into the
pandas route and we were going to see
these steps right now because in the end
what we are trying to do is not just
fixing the file I got our goal as users
of open data should be to have the file
fixed on the serving end to have the
your your city councils your countries
your regions publish data in the correct
form not just fixing what you got as a
download so let's go with the Hands-On
part of the session we are going to
figure out how do we validate single
data sets what do we mean by a single
data set um I'm trying to point that
whenever we're accessing a portal we
might find for example
a yearly reports of accidents and every
single year will have a
different data set so whenever we are
trying to validate one of these single
data sets we're going to try to figure
out if the the quality of the data set
include in this individual file is good
enough or
not and I just choose one kind of
randomly that my was not too complicated
that is the the bike theft this data set
is going to help us just to to figure
out where where the big is stolen where
which models what were the locations and
everything in between
so this is the one we're going to use
right now and this is kind of the
workflow we are going to go during the
session we are going to start by
defining some data requirements or that
data quality requirement re Ms we are
going then to create our
expectations then we are going to
validate if the data fulfills our
expectations if it doesn't fulfill them
we will create some pandas function just
to recover the files and to create this
variation and then we will just improve
the validation based on feedback so for
example if we detect that there are some
problem with a particular column we will
just fix the column and if we find some
something that is still wrong or still
broken we will kind of start the cycle
again we will redefine the requirements
and then go ahead with the
expectations so uh if you have any
previous questions from here it's time
to open your notebooks there is this
this single data set I python notebook
that we are going to
use and I just want to caution you
because we are we are going to go
through the whole process and the first
step is to go do you know anela
lur it's it's very famous like uh
Jessica Fletcher from the series a crime
she wrote where she was kind of a
detective so whenever we're trying to
approach this kind of open data set we
need to to change our mindset and go
into detective mode like um okay let's
see let's see if this is what I expect
it to be everything is going to be use
much more complex that you're expecting
even in this gold data set and I'm going
just to show you in one minute but yeah
let's go with this kind of detective
mode and the first thing we need to do
is just to explore the data domain if we
are checking about bike theft because
maybe I'm really concerned I just bought
a new bike and I want to know in my city
what are the the spots that maybe are
more dangerous for my bike to get stolen
or whatever let's say I want to analyze
this data set so the first thing is
going to learn about the domain what
kind of information is available what
kind of things do I need to know what
kind of yeah what what's in the files
and then we are going to perform a
exploratory data analysis so for this
thing we are going to be using our web
browser but also one of my favorite
libraries it's called sweet beast and it
creates a really nice a nice report from
our data for those that
are familiar with libraries for
exploratory data analysis you might know
about um pandas profiling also known as
H white data profiling and I have used
that extensively in the past but some of
the latest version were not compatible
with the latest version of python and
some of the parts that were compatible
with with respect ations are compatible
with older versions of great
expectations so in order not to
complicate it too much we're going to
use sweet be that maybe is not as full
feature as Panda profiling but it will
perform really well for our use case so
let's go to our browser and find out and
let's keep this in
mind don't trust anything beside data
you know the house doctor that say
everyone is lying every is lying it's
kind of yeah technically it's not lies
but usually you read things and you
might wonder okay is this what I
expected or not and usually there are
things that are not really clear there
are some updates that might not be there
there are some obsolete text there might
be missing files they might there are
all kind of things that might be broken
so with this in mind let's just go ahead
and
visit this open data Toronto to visit
the the website uh we open this Open
Toronto CA catalog and this is kind of
the the place where we can find most of
the data set there are
465 data sets found and if we are
we we need to find for example the
bicycle we just write here
bicycle and it will just return like
bicycle post and ring location parking
where are the Rocks where are the okay
as you can see there are there are a lot
of data set you can see which of them
are retired or which of them are not so
here we have the bicycle
theft um let's explore this page for a
moment here on the left we we can see
the data quality score that is gold it
was the refresh h two weeks ago it's
refreshed once a year it's a map that
deals with Public Safety and it follows
this kind of um external information so
we can see that this is published by the
police and you can find here the the
contact information and it's time to
read about this information about the
data set it says that the data set
contains a bicycle thiefs occur by
reported date and details regarding the
stolen item were available this includes
all the bicycle thefts reported to
Toronto Public Service included those
where the location has not been verified
so for example if the airport is not
inside the Toronto City and someone
reports to the police that their bike
was stolen there will be data about the
bike theft in the file but the
coordinates might not be there and also
it's it's another very interesting
things is that the fields that have been
included are for the all cities
structure the Toronto City neighborhood
structure as a new one and something to
keep in mind is that just to keep the
privacy of the of the people being
stolen the bike location have been some
kind of anonymize and they are offset to
the nearest Road intersection note so
even if the bike was stolen at your
house it will not level your house as
the place where it was stolen it will
just say
okay this intersection is where the the
problem happened so we might not have
really accurate things the main Pro the
main problem here may be houses that are
near one of the division or neighborhood
borders so maybe the bike is reported in
the in the other District or the other
division or the other neighborhood and
the house is actually on the other side
of the road so it's not 100% accurate
but okay that's that's something just to
consider whenever we are reading about
this so this is kind of the data preview
we can see like here um really
big concentration of bikes by the way I
just realized that the City airport is
here never been to Toronto maybe in
somewhere I will be there but so here we
can find information about the metadata
these are the data features this this is
the the offense date this is the the
year the month the day of the month the
date of the year the report month this
is kind of the metad data where is where
did this happen this is the division for
the for the police division where this
happened what time did the report
happened where it was stolen what kind
of premise what kind of
location what make of the bike there
there's all kind of information
available here and if we check here we
can see that what I talk before the the
data quality score how do they calculate
this so if we go down here we can see
like is the data set up to date we can
see the metrics here The Meta data is
well described the accessibility is not
okay is is there's missing data there
there's no missing data and well maybe
who
knows we will we will check this out
never trust whatever I mean we should
trust them but we will find out
so if we would like to download the file
and just proceed we can just click here
on CB format and click download this
could be a way to go ahead but another
most of these portals offer also an
interface called secan so you can like
explore the data and click it here to
visualize the file so you can kind of
preview what is available here on the on
the file um one thing that is very train
even though we have
seen in the in the description that it
was checked
for for missing missing values and it
said no missing values are variable the
file is 100% complete we can find here
some columns that have lot of blanks and
if we scroll
down yeah there there are there are tons
of blanks and even these are these are
supposed to be let me just scroll this a
bit for you these are the dates
and I assume that we are not getting
reports of medieval times
bikes so there's something strange with
this data set but anyway this is kind of
the first exploration uh I'd like you to
to whenever you are approaching just
take your time to go through the
metadata to go through the description
and if there are tools available to do
some preview that's perfect okay let let
me just move to the to the right hand
side here here and do
some um here in the geometry field we
can we can see that this is this field
is the one that is keeping the locations
and based on the what we've seen before
we can see here at grid as map this
seems to be well positioned because as
we can see most of the data here is
based on the on the Toronto area if we
kind of zoom out a bit we will see that
we have no reported bikes anywhere
around most of the geographical data
seems to be on place we can even cluster
this data to get a a better view of the
what are the most H Troublesome areas
that seem to be near here the the
airport area anyway we can explore the
data afterwards if we want to but right
now the things we are going to do is we
are going to move to BS code and we are
going to H explore the the data set just
from the beginning okay if you are not
able to follow right now along don't
worry you will have time you can just
take a look to a in a more relaxed space
afterwards so no worries so first thing
we're going to do we already did this is
to create a virtual environment and then
activate the virtual environment and
then install the requirements H in terms
of requirements what we are going to use
is sweet be for exploratory data
analysis is pandas for obvious reasons
IP Kel just so it works really fine and
fancy with BS code then Great
Expectations Library black for just
formatting so it looks like I don't have
to worry about the formatting and if we
need to download the file usually we
will use the request library and we will
use the open by Excel and Excel Rd just
to open Excel files in case we are not
able to use the
the regular the regular files
so let's just go to the to the single
data set I want to make sure you are
viewing the the screen
properly I would like to know if you can
confirm because I see it a bit dark oh
okay okay I see some hands okay maybe
it's just me that time see like a
bit well okay lot of times so thank you
for your okay perfect so time to move
ahead so like I said if you want to run
this on collab you will just run this
like um open collab and just paste the
URL and the thing the main cabet is that
you will need to create the the data
directories and you will need to Wate
the the file we will be using as it's
not imported automatically into collab
so let's start by by the beginning let's
just do the simple thing let's just go
ahead
and and just going to select the virtual
environment let's hope everything works
as expected as you know this is kind of
the the the the demo effect and here we
can see kind of the first registers that
according to what we've seen before it
looks quite quite interesting I mean we
have the event unique ID we have the
theft under we have the date there are a
lot of NS here you can see the year
month day of the week day day of the
year everything so let's just do some
what this is kind of first step we we
can do
with with pandas and if we see here the
results for example for OC date or for H
OC
report date out of the 34,000
registers in this particular Fields
there are
5,700 registers that are not n so that
this means around 28,000 of these
registers are are n I'm not really sure
how you can calculate 100%
completeness when your data has like 80%
missing values
but that's it at least you may get 90%
or whatever so we can see all the all
the previous dates we see like the dates
are are imported as objects um so we are
not getting this daytime object because
we of course in our pandas import was
not kind of the the best we could have
specified the data types and but we are
not going to do this in pandas but in
the G expectation H software
so let's start by performing a a
brief ER exploratory data analysis using
this sweet bits Library it's really
simple you just need to import the site
B and then you pass it the data frame
with the
analyze method and then you just use the
so HTML to get the report so usually
this will pop up in a new in a new
window and I'm going just to copy and
and paste it to my to my browser
so we can see it on the screen right now
this will help us to do some very basic
but very interesting we can see for
example here the association between
variables everything is kind of um
included by default and I think it's
really really interesting we can see
like some um relationship between the
the variables um let's let's focus right
now on the angle going to make it a bit
smaller so maybe you can see it like you
can see it
better okay so here in the screen you
can see for every single value you have
the the number of
values uh you can see here the number of
distinct values for for example the IDS
every single one of them
is different and if you click in any of
those you will get on the on the right
hand on the screen uh
uh more detail description so for
example for Evan unique ID here we can
we we start discovering very strange
things we were talking about this
detective mood we have a um variable
called event unique
ID and this event unique ID if we come
here to the bike thefts and check the
metadata we will see
that event unique ID is the number of
the
offense Okay so if we come here to the
report we see that there are some event
unique IDs that are used 14 times so
this is like very strange because I
expect the event unique ID to be
unique we will explore we need to keep
this in our mind to say okay why do we
have a unique ID that is used multiple
times we need to just go there and find
what's happening in the data if we go
for example to the to the OC date then
the missing values are around 83% this
is quite high as we knew then we need to
just focus on the
year we see the the the year values used
here on the on the right hand side we
can see like like the let me just move
this here and then here we we find
another very strange um let me just see
if I can so
okay in our data set description we got
this
um if we go there to the
metadata or to the
description H this says the data set
contain Bicycle St Ur from 2014 to
2020 then we go to the to the actual
dates and we see that this is
1975 198 3 200
2009 what are these values here why are
we finding this kind of values when when
they shouldn't be here at least this is
what we get from the just from the
description so if we move ahead and we
can go and Report year report month
report let's just go down to the
division for example these are like the
police division we see like most of the
crimes or the thefts happening two or
four this may be really useful to create
some kind of
visualization and then let's let's see
another thing that just stucks to my to
my mind is like here I I see I'm not
expert in in bikes but it seems like a
very common maker brand is OT UK GI
other and maybe OT stands for other and
there are unknown make what what you
know we we start digging into the
columns and then we need to figure out
okay there are 180 missing values here
but I assume the missing values are
unknown makes because this is the the
make columns so it's it's a bit strange
at least we we need to find out what's
happening here with the model bike May
I'm not even going to enter into the
speed or the cost of but you know here
this is kind of an
the first Vision I just go there and the
on my first view what do I see I see
that there might be some issues on the
on the data that is presented
here um okay there's some people
commenting and some people H offering
feedback thank you if you want to also H
ask on the
qna okay I will some people say I cloned
the project and then created data
quality
environment how do I marry this I think
if you want to do it with cond you need
to get a cond
environment and then just install the
required requirement using pip and then
open this uh using the local tool you
have for Jupiter notebooks maybe your ID
I don't know if you're using jet brains
or you're using BS code then double
clicking that and usually in BS code or
J brain you have to select the virtual
envir environment you are using I don't
know if any other of the other attendees
maybe can also help here in the chat so
that might be really helpful and really
useful so let's go back to
our BS code
or
um Jupiter notebook file so as we were
browsing this
I was like they maybe there is some
extra information because there are some
things that are not very clear for me
and fortunately here on
the on the on the own data set there is
this more information so there is always
the need for more information let's just
try to find more
information and this is this is where
where this kind of can of worms opens
and then
you're like oh my God I cannot believe
this yes this is this happens all the
time with open data so this is a map
with the with the location it's kind of
the same map that we've seen before with
all the
34,000 and well this is in Spanish I
assume if you are opening that up I'm
going just to paste it into the chat so
you can also browse it and and not just
see my screen maybe you also want to to
to brow same time as I'm doing here I
can click on The View All details
download H if I click here on the
download file I will just let me just go
back to a second to to the place where
we were before because here we can see
like Fields have been included both in
the
old neighborhood structure as well as
the new if I go here to the metadata on
the data features where is the
neighborhood
information is missing so we in the
description they say oh yeah you can you
can get the neighborhood data there is
no field for the neighborhood data in
our
file this is very strange I I want to
open the file and double check maybe
there is no information for real if you
have cloned the repo here in the input
file bikes folder Bicycle Thief CSV you
can get you can check this this this
file and if we see on the first row
the what is the information available it
it actually fits the description of the
metadata I mean the data features but
there is no information about the
neighborhood so if I want to present and
I want to to analyze what what
neighborhood had the most kind of thefts
I'm not able to do it because this
information is not here but and here
comes the surprise if I go to this
additional
info and just check kind of what are the
available
files if I click here on the download
file I will get another data file and
this is very strange because Public
Safety is publishing another
file and this other
file indeed has the information about
the neighborhood
you can see here it has information
about the neighborhood it has
information about the different District
it has additional columns but talking
about additional columns it has
additional columns here at the beginning
what are this kind of
coordinates I don't know this is not
either documented here on the on the
website so it's very very strange so the
what do we do we read a lot and then if
we come here to the to the let me just
go back to a second to the to the
preview site I mean public safety data
portal okay let me just go here back for
a moment if we go here to the external
link this link is a
map you will soon discover that there is
another website for the public safety
data portal where they have the
documentation so it's really nice they
have a document and they have a code
sheet so if you look here in the
document for bicycle oh this this is the
information I'm looking for okay this is
the file where is the X and Y column I
don't know it's not here so it's kind of
undocumented it's very strange uh it's
very very strange and if I click here I
like oh this is very nice they are doing
some documentation for me they're doing
some data visualization oh yeah this is
super nice now I can check all the all
this open data and if I click here on
the description it's like current year
to date is not available from thead but
yeah the the data is here I mean this is
kind of year to date and this is here on
the panel and maybe this is even in the
data so what I'm I'm trying to say I'm
going to sort this out is that whenever
you're approaching open data even if it
looks neat even if it looks clear
usually there are so many things going
around there are so many interesting bit
and pieces and you will need time just
to do your homework and figure out what
are the required data indeed if you look
about this data there is this Cod sheet
that has the the the code and the
meaning for the values we might be
seeing so UK is
not a brand of bikes is like unknown
value and unknown is unknown and well
this might be helpful when the bike
types are codified either the bike makes
are codified so it might be very useful
just to go and say okay this is what I
needed once I have this it's going to be
all a piece of cake no no way this is
open data we need to yeah it happens we
need to just there are so many pieces
Ming pieces departments City councils
everything moving around we need to
figure out our way through this thing
together so let's let's go and check the
the data set and let's
define what have we learned in this last
10 15 minutes
so location has not been able to be
verified so the coordinates may be
outside of Toronto the fields have been
included for the structures we've seen
that we have a data set that has this
information and there's no personal data
we see that the the claim for the the
thefts has expanded so we assume the
text is not
current and if
we check even if we check The Columns of
both both files as you see here on the
screen there are different columns most
of the columns are the same but there
are some columns that are different in
this particular table you can see the
difference I didn't do this by hand if
by the way if you paste both of the
columns to gp4 and say what is the
difference between these two data set
definition you will find it will offer
you very interesting Insight even even
to say that in the original descriptions
the
descriptions are wrong I mean this this
just stuck me the most if we go to the
to the original open data set and we
look to the data
features I mean we are not robots we are
not AI maybe we overlook this this is
the day of the year the offense happen
this is the day of the month no this is
not the day of the month this is the day
of the week there is no day of the month
so
the day of the year is this one this is
the day of the year and the day of the
year is the day of the week so even if
the data is okay the description is not
okay so if you are trying to automate
this you will get like crashing again
and again with this kind of
inconsistencies even in the best most
reported and most look data set in the
world so but still we can improve it
that that's what we're trying to do here
so let's not lose our minds and let's
move back back to the to the alternative
data set let's do a brief exploration of
the alternative data set let's just okay
it looks nice they are the same oh take
a look to this the OC date is okay it
there are no nuns here there are no
medieval times this is nice we have here
the times that looks nice this is an
improvement and even here we have the we
have
the oh the neighborhood so it looks
really nice even though there is a
column that has duplicate information it
looks really nice by the way the the
longitude and latitude is not the same
even for the same registers and this is
based on projections this is web
Mercator coordinate anyway let's try to
if you run the report you will see that
this file is much more better than the
one we found before but this is not
going to be the case that we usually get
one data set and if that fails you get
another one if usually this is like one
of a kind so let's see what what do we
learn here there's almost no missing
valubles in the data set that's very
nice and
even there are some
duplicates yeah the data is definitely
better by some reason there are most of
the occurrence date happens at night and
I just wonder if Toronto has a really
active night or maybe this is kind of
database leveling event that just
happens over
time uh yeah division has also a value
like NSA I assume is a National Security
Agency it's more like maybe not
associated we don't know it's not
documented anywhere
so what do we do now let's figure out if
in our actual data we we can just start
mixing Python and pandas here so for
example
if we want to visualize where is the
occurring date we'll see like most of
the date most of the offenes do not
happen at 4: or5 rather they happen
during the the the afternoons so I
assume there is some kind of Wess
happening there we will just s this out
so if we pack or unpack some of these H
duplicate event unique IDs we will see
that there are
14 bikes stolen at the same
time maybe they took a track and stole a
lot of them so they get them under the
same umbrella we don't
know every every single every single
occurrence here has ACT actually the
same unique ID but if we take a look to
the bike details they are different so
without this information we don't know
there are some different values there
are some different brands there are some
different speeds they are not definitely
did the same bike so we are going to
enter into the great expectation time
and then the first thing that we need to
do is like find out the plan part we
need to plant our observation what are
we trying to achieve what are we trying
to to get into and the first thing we
need to do is go back for a second to
the slides uh before we go further
because one of the most confusing things
that happens in the great expectation
times is that setting up the environment
is a bit complex so let me just before I
go back to the great expectation what
are we going to measure what are we
trying to achieve what are we going to
use G expectations for after our
exploratory data analysis we have
accuracy that says date should be in the
correct format bike brand should be
either s codes or brand name not a mixer
we shouldn't have like other OT unknown
UK okay no either one or the other then
we have completeness consistency and
stuff like that so let's go back to the
slides for a moment so I can just share
with you what are the what are the
things
that okay what are the expectations
great expectation is a library that
enables you just to instead of using
this kind of DF is null suum that get
the values the the the total summatory
of the null values you can just expect
the colum values not to be null this
reads much more better and it's much
more simple to follow along so G
expectation enables you to write these
checks and uh one thing to consider is
that great expectation is great to
validate your data and document your
data but is not it will not fix the data
problems for you you need to do it by in
your uh on your own okay so the main
idea is that you can connect to whatever
sources you
have
um okay whatever sources you have and
then I see that someone is has just
replied on the on the Q&A so thank you
Damian for the step by step and it will
be great for people following along so
the main idea is with Great Expectations
you have your data asset in whatever
format and Source maybe there are
database tables maybe there are fat
files there are panda files whatever you
need and then you're going to get the
data documentation and the the the I
mean high quality data this is the main
idea and you get some features to get
alerts in your slack or emails whatever
what does expectation look like this is
just a python function that looks like
this spec colum values not to be null
the good thing is you see see down there
in the bottom you see that this same
expectation works with pandas Apache
spark SQL L psql MySQL Microsoft SQL red
SI big query snowflake so the same
expectation can be used to check your
data with pandas now that the data is
imported into some other other source
this will be checked for you the great
expectation has several execution
engines and you can just make sure that
if this is like supported it will choose
the right back and to run your query and
if your SQL ER uses null or your Panda
uses none it will get the same result
because this is kind of one abrau level
on top
so good thing is that the uh at the GD
expectation uh Gallery if you go to
Gallery dogex expectations. I will just
open it up in a second you you will find
324 expectation written for you most of
them are available just for pandas so if
you see like the compatibility most of
them are kind of suited for pandas but
there are lots of them that are kind of
can be used for your cloud data
warehouses or whatever you are using for
so this is kind of the workflow we are
going to run through in our notebook we
are going to install G expectation we
already did that indeed with the when
you in in the the pimp install for the
requirements it will work for you then
we need to set up a context and then we
start like setting all these things this
is maybe the most complicated part of G
expectation wrapping your mind about the
way that this was set up but I I think
once we go through you will get the
point so the first thing we have a data
context so and on the on the broader
level this is the umbrella for you to
put on top of everything that is related
to a single topic so in this case our
data context will be related to B theft
but if you have like several different
servers connection tables sources you
could have several different data
contexts once you have a data context
you need to define the data source and
this might be very very common
for well for data engineers and people
working with databases this is kind of
the very common thing then you need to
say okay this is my
Source okay so usually for SQL service
is just your connection string and this
is I mean basically this is built on top
of SQL Alchemy so if it's supported by
SQL Alchemy probably it could work also
with G expectations but the good thing
is that you are saying okay in this
context my source of the data is going
to be this particular
server the most um strange part is that
for pandas the instead of having a
server you have a folder so you can have
that in a bucket you can have in an S3
bucket in a GCS Cloud whatever it's
going to be the folder and the folder is
going to be the instruction for the data
source inside each folder you can have
one or more files you can have one or
more tables and then you're going to
have to map your assets and the main
idea about the assets is that you are
going to be able to say okay this is my
asset this is like for this out of this
folder just get these two or three um
files and it will like just
uh get it right
so next thing you need to do is to slice
your record and this is this is where
things get complicated because so far
we've seen like okay we need a source we
need out of the source there are several
assets and then we are going to create
like a bat asset that is going to take a
slice of this data so let's say you have
a a table with millions of record but
you only want to retrieve the latest one
be saying okay this is the latest H this
is the table and just get the
latest I think the
new
okay okay I I got my my message like
this is your 30 minute Waring okay
perfect so this this is where the data
leaves these are my slices and then what
else do I need I need my expectations so
spe colum values to name
regx this look like really if you expect
colum values to match a certain regets
you know what you are kind of trying to
match here expect column volumes to be
unique okay it's it can be WR properly
so you get everything you expect for the
data under a suit of expect this is kind
of the the the bigger level um struction
like an expectation should and there are
two ways to validate one is to use an
interactive validator where you say okay
this is the data this is these are the
expectations figure out if they match
each other or if once you have
everything ready you can say okay I'm
going to take this expectation to
production so whenever I run this
checkpoint I want you to check this
batch information against this shoot and
then get the results and if things get
really wrong and if something happens
just run these actions so these are kind
of the way that we evaluate that and out
of the whole process you will get a HTML
dogs that is kind of a report of what
happened work did it work you will get
plain HTML files that can be saved to a
local
folder Okay so
I think we got most of the things
covered let's go back to the code first
thing we do is to
just create the this kind of er data
context here then you go to connect to
the data source name and then you say
here okay I'm connected to this data
folder that is the data input bikes here
in our case it's data input bikes here I
have my CSV files okay
so next thing I need to do is I need to
say out of all the files here just pick
this
file here you can do like monthly files
yearly files I'm just getting one single
file but you can work with several files
that I think that's very very
interesting then I'm going to say okay
get the whole content of the file and
save it as a b request so this is kind
of the inmemory uh config contents of
the file under the hood this is just
calling pandas here I I don't know if
you have seen here we are like creating
our data source adding a pandas file
system resource so this is kind of the
folder and then we are going to create
one expectation suit to serve as
umbrella for all the configurations and
checks we're going to go moving forward
so here we have that and then we need to
create a validator like I said validator
is an object used by G expectations just
to check in an interactive way if the
validations are okay or not or if the
expectations are okay or not and you
will see here the expectations in a
really clear way so for example let's go
with the first once we have the
validator object we can TR we can start
uh testing the expectation so for
example I'm going to test if the event
unique ID called volum is all
unique and here we can see like oh sorry
if you skip one of those you you're dead
so if we calculate if we click the
button here here we can see the results
and we see in the result that the result
is false so it
didn't H fulfill the the
this I expected the column values to be
unique and he said no it's not that's
not correct out of the 34,000 rows we
got
6, 700 Val rows that are not unique so
this is kind of 20% of the of the whole
data set and these are all
the rows that did not fulfill your
expectation that did not as validate so
there are no missing values here and the
total for this is like 20%
so think about a a file that is created
every single year and this is like okay
if the the number of uh the percentage
is over 30% I want to get a warning
otherwise it's kind of normal I can use
a keyword called called mostly that can
be just used to evaluate if this is
correct for um 80% of the of the
resources so let's say I'm I'm allowing
this to fail for up to 20% of in total
so it's passing now okay here you can
see success equals true I am assessing
this column ID and I'm I know that 20%
of the resources are not ER unique but
other than that this is passing let's
check if the division values start by D
because I've seen there before that um
every single division started by D and
it look like it should start by D I'm
checking this oh it's not okay now now
you know that you know the drill it's
like okay it's not that the the values
are not are not matching this regular
expression I'm getting 110 errors it's
0.3% and this is my list of values okay
given I'm doing this kind of interactive
run by
then I can just update this I'm going
here to update my regular expression to
be NSA or any
digits so again I'm going just to check
this out now I'm getting it right
everything in the file is either
starting by d uh or is NSA of course you
can find alternative regular
Expressions now we go with the big issue
okay we had the
bike um
the bike brand or the B makers and I'm
going to create a list here with all the
brands in the file these are all the
brand that appear in the file and even
I'm I'm going to create a dictionary so
I get all the either aqu or Aquila bar
barleta all these kind of Brands so I
can check using this expectation expect
column values to be in the set I pass
the column and I pass the list and it's
going to check if every single row is in
the list otherwise it's going to throw
an error and it says no out of the
32,000 24,000 of the of these are not in
the in the brand makers list okay I'm
going just to find out if at least I'm
they're using the circles no 57,000 of
these values are not either
there okay it's this is getting quite
complicated let's see if I merge both
the sore codes and the maker codes I'm
getting better results yeah and getting
better result but there are like
around
9,000 registers that have other values
so i' say you would need to spend a lot
of time to get this right to get this
without any kind of of problems it's
like you just check your assertions in a
really methodical way with really to
follow really simple to follow along
sentences so you can validate every
single time every date should be in the
correct format okay here I I'm just
saying spe colum volumes to be date util
Parable so here I'm using the date util
library to see if all the dates are
correct and yeah all of them are correct
W that's that's very nice even though if
I check here on the lower part the
missing count is
28,000 so for the items that are there
they are compliant with the I mean they
are compliant with this kind of
particular particular rule because NS
seem to be also Parable they just in
terms of returning none they return not
a time so it's kind of a pain
so as I just know that there was some
issue there H with the with the dates
let me just say if all the resources
there are between 2014 and
2023 I go ahead and check it out and I
see it falls there are resources for
another year most of them most of them
are for
2013 okay we are doing this in an
interactive way we can just change the
way we're mesing measuring out so we see
that there are 10 values that are
outside of the scope but let me just
check for the report
year it seems it's true so all the
report years are between 203
2023 so when someone said okay this data
is between these two dates it's not
talking about the date about the offense
but the dates when it was reported so
someone in 2023 reported that their bike
was stolen in 1975 this is very strange
but it might happen and let's make sure
we just we don't want to have any B any
columns date columns with nonone Valu so
we are going to check that and if we get
the results we've seen like okay out of
this 34,000 elements we are getting this
28 um errors now that we have set up
everything we want to try now that
everything is kind of settling Stone and
I'm keeping the latest version I'm just
going to save this to a checkpoint that
is going to um create a launter
validation where I could like throw
actions and fix things but but to make
it simpler I'm just going to save the
expectation suit and then I'm going just
to run my checkpoint this is going to
calculate all the metrics all the
expectation in all the previous data and
then we have here a way to build our dat
data docs and here we get this
URL I'm going to open this up for a for
a
minute this is what we are
getting
so here we can see this is our our local
documentation if we click here we can
see the option we can see expectation
and I can see out of all the expectation
that were evaluated five were successful
four were not and I can see here this
very nice report like for example for Ev
unic
ID there are some unexpected values for
the OC date
there are like for example there are
Parable by date util but there are lot
of nules so this is kind of my report
and then I'm going to use pandas just to
fix all these problems or I'm going to
try I'm going to do my best so here I'm
just going to copy the the the data file
I don't want to overwrite any any
initial file I'm just going to create a
new data frame and I'm going to make all
the all the changes I'm just going to
check
to see for example here I have other
unknown UK all these kind of different
values so I'm going to start by fixing
the bike brands I'm going to fix H
what's happening here I'm going just to
replace the using the dictionary I'm
going just to replace the short codes
with a long H
form and I'm going to see if this looks
a bit different yeah now I have like I
have this other brand that was split
into OT and other now for example that
has Consolidated so I'm I'm trying to
fix at least the brand but if I if you
take a look to the data there are like
ebikes there are a lot of other values
that are not H really nice other thing I
could do given that there are
180 missing values and I don't know what
are what is the make I can just fill
those with unknown make so it will make
it will be more consistent that we've
what we've seen
ER
before
so here I'm going to try to fix the
dates and I see Maro asking what is the
format of date that it validates by
default the the that expectation just
uses
the ER par dat utility of pind
library but the main issue here if you
want to set to a certain format there is
a validation that you can pass a string
format and it will check against
whatever string format you want so you
can here we are we are just creating one
ISO
8,601
formatting so what we are going to what
we are trying to do is to create the OC
date by converting the year the month
and the day to Strings and then just
getting them together and boom we just
discovered that the months are not in
the particular format so we are just
going to again create a dictionary and
do the mapping and then boom all our
dates are not in the medieval times are
just in normal times they like more
recent dates and we we've so two things
here we have filled the blanks but also
we have overwritten the grown dates so
we are using pandas to make the best out
of this situ sitation we are also going
to do that for the report date column so
we get everything perfectly fine now
what's the next step we had two data
sets we have two things to to fix what
do we do well if if it was me I wouldn't
use the file with the medieval times I
would just use the better quality data
set from the start but given we are just
trying to find our ways let's go ahead
and do some manual fixing here for your
enjoyment we are going to split the
columns that have neighborhoods and the
it's neighborhoods
and yeah this is the kind of it has the
code and the description so I'm going to
split that into two columns by using uh
another
formula and yeah what what's the point
right now we are going to mix everything
together we are going to create a UniFi
data set and this is going to be so
sweet what what do we need to do now we
have changed everything in pandas
everything is sorted out our file should
be better do not trust anything even
myself doing this kind of data quality
checks let's go to the final
validation okay this is what we have
here we have already defined our context
we have our expectation suit this is
what we want to T test against what do
we need to do now okay we need to import
the new CSV file with everything Chang
we need to set this as an asset we need
to retrieve the contents and we need to
check against as a
checkpoint we are going to do this in a
single step as everything is here
described um here and the good stuff and
the good um part the the best thing we
we we got out of this we go to the final
point where we we create another
checkpoint and we can compare different
runs in our
context we've seen before that the the
the docks are inside the context so if I
let me just okay where is
my I'm trying to speed up it's not I'm
not sure it's resulting in much more
comprehensible talks so okay here we
have our expectation results and we can
see that our results are the original
test and the fixed test this the
original text or the original
test had nine expectation five
successful four fail if I go back here I
check here I have nine expectation seven
successful two unsuccessful so if I go
down here I will say like for example
now I don't have any null values for my
date and this is interesting because we
can keep track of how we go forward and
how we improve our results and how we
can just document what are the
expectations about our data so what have
we learned in this run with a single
file reports will keep track of the
Improvement will help you get um better
results maybe it doesn't fix everything
for example the bike brands will require
a lot of time just to get everything
perfect but just figure out what I need
to improve so it's useful for my project
and also make clear that whenever you
need to communicate your requirements
other people will be able to help you
and assist you because you have that
documented so I'm going just to there's
another part that will take like hours
just to I would just realized afterwards
like how to work with h long-term
files and I'm just going to say that
long-term f is like how do we get files
together how do I get several years into
a single data file it has its own set of
challenges but there are kind of
basically three problems like data grows
over time so the headers are not
consistent here you can see kind of the
step you need to remediate this using G
expectations and just
to H ask some questions I will just go
to the end of this multiple data set
files and I'm going just to present you
some examples of expectations real
expectation that can be found in the
real world when for example analyzing
public contracts in my city of Madrid so
yeah you can see here some expectations
like you can have the values to match
particular reg regular expression you
can have check if values are unique if
they're parable if there are parts of a
set if there are if the if the here we
have been talking about column
expectations but there are also table
expectation you can see if the name of
the columns over the years have changed
you can see if all the files are the
same or not and you can do this in an
programmatically way
so that's kind of I don't know if there
are some particular questions I think I
have answered some of those during the
presentation if you want to
ask um I I know we
are
okay just to wrap up a few years
ago haly ggman just presented open data
about tidy data and how to sort these
things out so everything that moves your
data to this kind of final version where
everything is separate every row is
different it's an observation every
column is available there are no messy
things there are no mixed things it's
going to be um
perfect and yeah all the materials are
there I don't know if there are some
question I've seen some of the comments
here that um people thought that it
could be really useful to validate the
format Maru asked is it able to validate
a big files h i I would say yes um I
would I think that part of the uses of
this solution is integrating with
bigquery with red SE with all these kind
of Big Data H warehouses so yeah the
performance of course depends on the on
the back end but I'd say the library is
quite
performant but again usually I'm mostly
dealing with with these kind of smaller
files coming from open data but yeah I I
think that it will work of course if
it's super big file if it's like real
real time streaming data maybe there are
some scenarios where it doesn't work but
there are others where it kind of excels
doing this um yeah this kind of
validation for me the most interesting
part regarding to open data and why why
I chose open data for this presentation
is that whenever you're having a
conversation with a public
body H it's like everyone has different
expectations and if the expectations are
not written down it's very hard to to
see if everyone is talking about the
same things it's like it's not really
simple to say oh this the the data
quality is very bad and they will say no
why do you say that with this tool you
can say okay I'm checking this thing I
checking that thing um and again I'm
going back to the root CA I hope this
video makes its way to
Toronto H open data Administration s and
eventually they fix the the issues with
the data set or just talk to each other
and say okay maybe it's a bit confusing
to have two files or maybe there's
another way so we can update the
metadata so it it's get like really
updated on
time so I don't know if there are some
particular questions for all of you I
see Gabor here Maro Alexandra I I would
like to thank you all for coming
okay how can we collaborate to taste
with a big file sending our feedback I
don't know Mar if you could like spand
your question a bit you would say how
can we collaborate to
test with uh you mean send it your
feedback to the to the Greet
expectations team one of the I well okay
I haven't talked about this but usually
great expectation has a very active
Slack Channel where people hang out and
talk about how to get started how to try
things there are lot of people trying
this with snowlake with Amazon ws and
and all these providers even G
expectation is now providing their own
version and there is also a discourse
platform like Discord great
expectation ER yeah and I will go back
to Eric question in a moment but I will
say hang out either in the slack if you
want more active community with other
people and if you want long-term
communication there is this discourse
place for conversation Eric is saying
can we gr custom complex expectation yes
it's really kind of really simple well
more or less simple if you go to Great
Expectations H site like Great
Expectations do okay let's go for a
second to docs H greet
expectations. if you go here there is
the is create
expectations how to uh create custom
expectation there are some templates for
columns for batches um for column pairs
like to check if one column is like
another and the good thing is you you
you want for example to create a a
column expectation here you have like a
quick start guide you it's like you get
a template and you start from there you
kind of customize the way it's called
and then you save it to your plugins
file and it gets imported whenever you
want to run for example I created one
that is have the column names to match a
particular regular expression so I
haven't so I
haven't presented the expectation
Gallery but here you have they're like
core these are the you see some of those
some of the expectation that say this is
like kind of core expectation like this
is like supported like this is like
contri column aggregate expectation this
is a custom function this is a function
that just comes into the regular GD
expectation file so you see like there
are around 85 core expectations and
around 2500 created by the community so
I'd say it's not complex just to get
your own expectation created once you
grab up your mind around this concept of
validators and all the logic inol I
think it's really really nice just to
get started and and to create your own
custom version and maybe certain with
the community because this is part of
the value of of being able to work with
open source H Solutions and like I said
here you can also filter by the kind of
maturity status experimental beta or
support you can also check of the the
kind of the contributors the items you
can see here FAS is kind of the most
supported but for all of the others
there are there are a lot of support too
so H thank all of you one last question
on the
Q&A okay it it was Moses saying if you
have any question please write them down
here on the Q&A question I think we are
running out of time I like to thank you
a lot for coming to this presentation I
hope it spark your interest that it go
you engage in involv in data quality in
general just to find out what's wrong
with the data sometimes is not really
simple to put it into words and with
this expectations it makes much simpler
to communicate to document to validate
and everything done with python so I
think it's a really
worthwhile tool to try and yeah let's
move to our better quality H in all our
data and if you want to keep keep in
touch um I'll be here on the herid
platform for a while and and yeah you
can just contact me and I'll be really
happy to to get in touch with
you um thank you so much this Eric Maro
um and also
Donovan and all the people at Pata that
has been supporting and Moses I like to
thank you all for your time and let's
keep on enjoying this spy dat Global
conference and see you soon on the P
data loc tabs everywhere